Am I right in understanding you've had a
fallout with Tommy Robinson?
>> Yes. Were you friends with him before?
And and why did you fall out?
It's a long story.
Uh if I say on online, they will be big
divide. It was bust before that. Huh?
Something happened before that. I did
post his son picture. I posted a picture
of a boy with face covered
and posted that people who are giving
money
to patriots
that they are doing good for the
country. They are using money on
expensive watches.
You have to shake I told the people to
shake hand with the radical Sikh give
rape threat to my daughter, then why you
fighting with other girls who are raped
by Muslims? You should shake hand with
Muslim also then.
Right. If you want me to shake hand with
these people, you cannot be hypocrite.
If you're fighting for a girl, you
should fight for every girl, not only
for white girls.
His Sikh friend exposed where his money
was going to his son's private jets and
Rolex watches, look what happened. Let's
find out for ourselves in sha Allah.
If you care about the dunya more than
the akhirah, skip it. By one donation,
you're going to have 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people have been fed
through the emergency food aid. You are
going to be sponsoring 4,200 orphans.
You will be helping 250,000 people in
Gaza. You'll be helping 123,000 people
to be fed through our Qurbani program.
You will help feed 551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 masajid are going to be built around
the world. And 74,000 given clean safe
water. That's why we want to keep one
Ummah 100% donation policy. And in order
for us to keep 100, we need you to help
us by supporting this fund so that all
of the stuff that I mentioned, you get
the reward for every single one of them.
It's far more important than the dunya.
And you will see every penny that you
give on Yawm al-Qiyamah. The decision is
yours. The link is there. Tommy
Robinson's Sikh friend, his staunch Sikh
friend who is trying to suck up to him
thinking that when they are getting rid
of all the immigrants, he's going to be
let off. No, my friend, you're going to
be dumped as well. And they've just
proven and shown that. Here is the video
in sha Allah brothers and sisters we're
going to be reacting to, and you are
going to be shocked. Let's get straight
into it. This is a video interviewing
this Sikh guy, which is Sikh community
is free way yeah. Okay, let's not make
our Sikh brothers and sisters in
humanity who have lovely discussions at
my dialogue table um uh warrior-like uh
individuals with their warrior-like
names and lovely discussion dialogues.
We might have our differences, but here
is the crux of the matter. His Sikh
friend exposed where his money was going
to his son's private jets and Rolex
watches, look what happened. Let's find
out for ourselves in sha Allah. So,
you've mentioned the United Kingdom
March. And am I right in understanding
you've had a fallout with Tommy
Robinson?
>> Yes. Were you friends with him before?
Not like friends known to him. He was
like big talk. Best exchange messages.
I've been to his stage couple of time to
the rally on the stages.
It was good. And and why did you fall
out?
It's a long story.
Uh if I say on online, they will be big
divide
in that moment.
>> Well, is it he he said I think or at
least
well, it seems to me when I've looked
into it, it's because you posted
pictures of his son whilst he was in
prison, is that
>> It was not it Okay, so this guy, I
forget his name is Harman or whatever
his name is Harman or whatever his name
is, yeah. Okay, posted pictures of Tommy
Robinson's son with the private jets and
asked some questions. Now, did he post
pictures of his son
um in a malicious way? Oh, no, no, no,
no, no. He did the right thing. This
person who's a idiot idiot You're an
idiot. You're an absolute idiot. Yes,
look what he's done and look how Tommy
Robinson got rid of him. It was bust
before that. Huh? Something happened
before that. I did post his son picture.
I posted a picture of a boy with face
covered
and posted that people who are giving
money
to patriots
that they are doing good for the
country. They are using money on
expensive watches.
Luxury holidays. I posted that.
And I posted a picture of a boy but but
no face. I didn't mention who is he.
Team Tommy
They mentioned that he's a son of Tommy,
not me.
If you go on the
comments, it's team Tommy. Their own
people. Their inner circle. So, it was
He was even afraid to say whose son it
was. He was that Listen.
He's embezzling money. He's taking money
with his cocaine snorting parties like a
little flipping crackhead. Okay, while
his son is on private jets and Rolex
watches.
Yes, you patriots, you are donating your
money to these dirtbags. And on 16th
May,
my dialogue table will be active in
Leicester Square, and I would love to
have a dialogue with you guys. I believe
most of you guys are genuine people who
have genuine concerns, and I would love
to have a dialogue. You can come see me
in Leicester Square. Danny Tomo,
uh flipping what's his name? Liam Tuff,
who's not so tough. Yes, come and see
me. Come and see me for an intellectual
uh debate discussion, yeah. Okay. Um any
of you far-right
whoever you guys are, okay. To an
intellectual debate and discussion, come
and see me. Uh but yeah, he exposed
Tommy Robinson's son for doing this
without mentioning the name, and Tommy
was upset with him. How dare you show
them where my money is go where the
donation money is going. Tommy's son.
>> It was, but nobody knows. But you didn't
show the face.
>> No, no, no, no. No face. But
nevertheless, they felt like it was a
threat, and I could understand why they
would feel that way. That they would
feel protective over No, they don't feel
protective because I
>> What's there to be protective over? He's
saying you are
using the money given to you patriots to
get rid of us Muslim grooming guys or
whatever you want to call it, yes.
Apparently, yes, while you've got the
Peter File Islands funded by Mossad in
Israel getting young white girls so they
can blackmail the elite to go and fight
your war in Iran so you can flipping pay
£1.83 per liter of petrol.
Before I know Tommy is
doing good
before knowing knowing Tommy. I think he
was doing really good for the country.
He's fighting for the cause.
But the one day when Tommy was in the
prison
Liam Tuff called me.
Inner circle of Tommy, Liam.
He asked me to shake hand with the
radicals
from my community because of which I
came to this activism who attacked my
home, give rape threats to my wife,
licked photo of
>> Sikh radicals.
>> Sikh radicals, Khalistanis.
And they were threatening to rape your
wife.
>> Yeah, it's on record, everything on
They're licking photo of my daughter, my
wife on social media on live stream.
So they attacked my restaurants. My one
other restaurant was closed 2 3 years
ago. Um my Bentley was broken. I think
they shot the Bentley and other car was
broken by them. Attacked by them several
times.
And I tried to get help from police.
Police done nothing because they were on
siding the radicals.
After that, I
>> So, there were radical Sikhs.
Interesting. So, there's radicals in our
faith. Interesting. It's in that
far-right. Um so, they attacked him and
they gr um
um
said they're threatening to rape his
wife and his daughter. I'm sure Tommy
Robinson doesn't want anyone to be
groomed or raped or for that matter. You
know, let's see if Tommy Robinson helped
his Sikh buddy here. joined Tommy. And
Tommy was the one who came to my
restaurant first time.
Not me going to Tommy.
And he knows that I I had a fight with
these radicals.
He told me, "Harman, you need to
leave this area because they are very
dangerous people." I tell I'm not
leaving London because everybody is
leaving London and they are
captured by radicals and other people.
Well, I'm not leaving London. I'm going
to stay and fight.
Then he called me to his rally in June,
1st June or 2024, I think was that.
I don't know, but I think 1st June 2024.
I've been to his rally. And then I get
lot of love of people. People loved me
because there there not many
brown people in the rally.
Yes, and if you come to our rallies, it
shows that we're not racist, you know.
Funnily enough, we tried to came to the
rally. We was invited and we got
physically attacked. Not any Sikhs. So,
I was called in the backstage. I was
there. So, things was very good.
Tommy knows about the everything.
But when Tommy was in the prison
Liam called me to shake hand with same
radicals who gave me death threat, rape
threats to my family.
I told Liam Woah, Liam. Liam Tuff,
you're not so tough, are you? So, you
was asking this man, who's a coward He's
a coward as well. Uh asking him to shake
hands with some radical Sikhs, which he
did not I believe he's a radical
um Sikh
for that matter.
So, you asked him to shake hands with
individuals who are trying to threaten
to rape his daughter and his
wife and trying to groom them whatever
that matter. So, you wanted because of
the cause to shake hands with these
radicals. And this man at least had some
principles and he said no. So, Liam
Tuff, you want people to go handshakes
with people who are threatening other
people's wives daughters
um to um be, you know, raped.
Interestingly, Liam. I'm sure you stand
up for, you know, you know, all kind of
grooming gangs and all that kind of
stuff. Yeah, I'm sure you guys again
pedophilia, yes.
Who told you They told me that we have
talked with Tommy already on the phone.
We are talking with him now from
last 2 3 days. Things are getting out of
hand. Tommy told me to ask you to shake
hand with radicals. If you cannot, you
are not part of us. I tell them, "Let
Let it be." Why would why would they
have wanted you to do that? Why would
Liam say they would have wanted you to
do that? Because they told me that these
people are our friends. The enemy of my
enemy is my friend. Okay. So, in a
nutshell, they asked him to shake hands
with the radical. And he's at least he
had some principles. At least you know,
he's a he's a he's a deluded man who
doesn't understand he's going to be
shipped on the boat after they get rid
of Muslims. But at least he had some you
know, decency.
You have to shake I told the people to
shake hand with the radical Sikh give
rape threat to my daughter, then why you
fighting with other girls who are raped
by Muslims? You should shake hand with
Muslim also then.
Right. If you want me to shake hand with
these people, you cannot be hypocrite.
If you're fighting for a girl, you
should fight for every girl, not only
for white girls.
Uh okay, interesting. So, firstly, what
have the faith of Islam or Muslim got to
do with it? Yes, what's what's that got
to do with anything? Yeah? So, these
radicals that you're talking about, why
don't you identify them as Sikh?
You dirtbag, Harman whatever your name
is, why don't you identify these
radicals who are threatening to rape
your wife and your daughter as Sikhs?
If these grooming gangs
are Muslim, which have got nothing to
Islam, then why don't you refer to them
as Sikhs? Why do you refer to all those
white pedophiles as Christians?
And the Zionist scum scumbags who are
coming raping your American and white
girls, yes, and going back to Israel
with the safe return
return of safe safety return of his
court, yeah, okay.
Right to return whatever it is for that
matter. You're telling me to shake hand
with these radicals. No.
I am not. If you don't want me part of
your group, get lost. I But I didn't
believe that that Tommy told them. Then
I
been to couple of court cases of Tommy
where he was getting some things
happening. So, I've been to briefings
which the states that
uh Tommy was on phone with all his
families and friends every day for 2 3
hours every day. So, I realized Tommy
knows everything and Tommy instructed
Initially, I thought that Tommy didn't
instructed this.
But you don't know. You you you're
speculating.
I I I know because Now I know.
Because
when Tommy was arrested, been to court,
everywhere, I was everywhere supporting
him.
My wife's leg was broken. In the
wheelchair, I took my wife to the prison
cell outside prison cell. I took her to
rallies everywhere in the wheelchair
supporting Tommy. He He took her to
Tommy's prison cell.
>> Yeah.
Outside prison
prison not cell prison.
Just I was coming back from the Peter
Lynch funeral
and same day was Tommy's birthday.
So, I we been outside and just shouting
happy birthday Tommy. Can you imagine?
He took his this He took his wife who
hurt herself or has a disability or
whatever it is for that matter in front
of Tommy Robinson's cell shouting happy
birthday Tommy. And then Tommy was given
a phone call to Liam Tuff telling him,
"Hey, listen,
tell him to shake hands with the
radicals who wants to rape his wife that
he took that to shout happy birthday and
his daughter."
You can't make this up. Look at the
humiliation. And Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says in the Quran which I'm going
to just quickly go to this. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the Quran,
"Indeed there is more fear in their
hearts for you believers than for Allah.
That is because That is because they are
people who do not comprehend. Even
united, they would not dare to fight
against you except from fortified
strongholds or from behind walls. Their
malice for each other is intense. You
think they are united, yet their hearts
are in divided. That is because they are
people with no real understanding. They
are both They are both just like those
who recently went down before them. They
tested the evil consequences of their
doings and they will suffer a painful
punishment.
They are like Satan when he lures
someone to disbelief. Then after they
have done that, so he will say on the
day of judgment, "I have I have
absolutely nothing to do with you. Truly
fear Truly I fear Allah, Lord of the
whole worlds."
We done that, yeah. I done a lot because
>> Peter Lynch was the guy who died in
prison.
>> Yeah.
Who was arrested after the Southport
killings? Yes. For some tweets, right?
>> Some tweets. Just Was it tweets or was
he at He was at some protest throwing
some stuff on police something like that
or something like that.
>> And he was an older man.
>> Older man he was at the He died of a
heart attack or something like that in
prison or
>> Yeah, I don't know what the actual cause
is, but he died. So,
on the way back from the his funeral, I
we been outside the prison cell.
I've been to his batches where he did
his absence.
I done everything for him. Yeah. But
what the team Tommy
did what they did with me and asked me
to shake hands with the radicals that I
thought, "No, this man
is
not here for a cause.
He's not racist. No.
He's not pretty yet. He's opportunistic.
Anybody show him something some money,
he will work for that guy. Put it on
record.
I seen that. So, there you go. There you
go. And guess what? What did the Mossad
Israeli said? He's cheap
and easy or something like that. He's
cheap like cheap and cheerful. Yeah,
okay. He's cheap and cheerful. Yeah,
okay. And that's what he is. You think
he gives a crap about you British people
genuinely? You guys genuinely think this
dirtbag Tommy who snorts cocaine lives
in his amazing mansion etc. Look,
listen, myself, yeah, I did Uber.
Yes, I was driving Uber. You know Uber?
Uber, okay.
Because it's not about the money. We're
not coming here and there doing this
this etc. Okay?
They don't care about you.
If anything, we Muslims care about you
because we say drugs is bad for you.
Alcohol is bad bad for you. Same-sex
marriage is bad for you. Gambling is bad
for you. Pornography is bad for you. All
this stuff is bad for you. And guess
what? Who Who own these kind of
industries? Zionists who are trying to
poison your kids, your children. Yes, to
be degenerates. And we as Muslims are
coming saying, "No, fight it." If
anything, we Muslims genuinely care
about Britain and the British people.
Same people
who this Liam asked me to shake hand,
they
contacted me a week before. They want me
to be part of their radical group. I
said them get get lost because it's too
late. I don't want to If anything, I
don't want to be a part of a radical
group.
This is not in Sikhism. Plus, you same
guys you give rape threats to my family.
You attacked my home and you want me to
be your friend.
Then they told me, "If you're not going
to shake hand with us, we are going to
team Tommy."
Sorry, I think you actually did answer
this earlier, but I just want to make
sure I've understood this. When you're
calling these guys radicals, the Sikh
radicals,
>> Yeah.
they're not political radicals. They're
poli Anyways, you know in a nutshell,
guys, that's it, yeah. Okay, he calls
them political radicals because they
want their own state and country as
Sikhs as Palestinians do. That's why
you know he calls them radicals or
whatever it is for that matter.
In a nutshell, guys, this video should
be shared
to like as much as possible to the far
right. So, you guys can see the reality.
Tommy don't give a crap about you. Don't
need Tommy don't give a crap about you.
These people don't give a crap about
you. All they want you to do is hate
Muslims because Muslims are the
scapegoat because the people who are
behind this is Zionists, yes, who are
controlling everything from social
media, you name it. Okay? They are
pushing the degeneracy so your kids kids
kids great great grandchildren could be
degenerates who do degenerate stuff.
Okay? Islam is saying, "No, stay away
from that. Wake up to the reality of
these scums." Okay? Tommy doesn't care
about you. He's not a patriot. There
were patriots who were killed in
Palestine helping the poor. Okay? And
like I said before, any of you guys want
to dialogue in a discussion, a sincere
dialogue discussion, talking,
Saturday, 16th May, I'll be in Leicester
Square.
And my table will be there. And I would
like to have a a nice discussion, a
simple discussion, and we can talk about
everything you want to. Okay? And I want
you guys to be consistent though. Okay?
Because we're going to call out the real
pedophiles.
Yes, the real real pedophiles that
uh the the um
uh that um
uh Tommy Robinson uh fits the profile.
Okay? Uh he's a middle-aged white man.
Okay? He fits the profile of a pedophile
that I could ever be. So, I'm ready to
discuss with you guys there. And if you
guys want to come, it'll be a pleasure
to speak to you guys and come to a
common term and understanding. Till next
time. As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi
wa barakatuh.
Hello, can you send that to me, please?